people really believe in an Illuminati
[ __ ] oh yeah do you believe in it tell
the truth don't [ __ ] don't go based on
the way I set up Jason speak your truth
you know I won't judge we interrupt our
program to bring you this important
message Instagram I just went ham on my
dad's business always trying to innovate
help my pops came up with a ridiculous
concept the least friction ever the most
convenient way ever to buy wine the link
is in my profile right now go sign up
ASAP you're part of the first little
group in the beta-test wine text dock
i'm you sign up right now takes you a
minute or two and then going forward
every day you get an offer on
ridiculously discounted wine this $45
Pinot is gonna be 18 bucks in an hour
that's right
18 the easiest way to buy anything ever
you get a ridiculous deal you know
multiple times a week and all you have
to do when you get the text is reply
with a number four and four bottles are
on their way I just went on it i flex it
on a wine business i helped on my pops
wine tax calm get on it now sign up now
share this now hitting your story now
wine lovers rejoice you got your
prospective
to be happy don't you want to be happy
you could literally create the
Thanksgiving game cops respire fighters
working backwards you of a law firm and
we want to get people's businesses and
so we first responders are they are
incredible lead-gen to that if they no
one like you a trust view from distance
that you've been doing yep
I totally agree so just as somebody who
I guess thank God hasn't been in this
scenario yet and just haven't dug in
some accident happens and the relatives
that are left over that aren't at the
hospital may look at a cop or a first
responder and say can you give me a
lawyer right now yeah it's cool I just
have never yeah I totally understand
what I'm really good at is not knowing
anything and asking questions right
curiosity and lack of education has been
an incredible foundation for me but you
think about all that stuff on remanent
television where the lawyers are there
right and I'm like you know and then
when I got older and like when I started
like just through like being in a
business cocktail you hear like some of
those companies are sizable businesses
and I'm like make sense right and so
when I started going to this version no
different than now like hey guys make
something that's valuable to people
instead of right I was like man I even
think in my earliest videos when I was
talking about personal brand I was like
be the lawyer that tells people all the
real [ __ ] like like like I just feel
like that's great that makes so much
sense to me so now we understand that
now so now what you're asking me is
targeting capabilities that if you're in
a town that all the cops are
irish-american like how do I win that
cohorts how do I best go about becoming
that alpha
in the psycho and demographic
communities by providing each one of
them what they're looking for either in
the macro or the micro of what you do
for a living so for you know the reason
SMB works for me so much is like I'm
trying to tell them to put out content
about how to fire a relative has nothing
to do with their product but I know
that's a huge value to actual SMBs I
think the answer is you the way I think
about that is you take the how many
different communities do you think there
are intuitively and I think you what you
do is you whiteboard the 10 that you
think are the most meaningful then rank
them and then really go deep in the
first three of like really spending time
whether reading what they're actually
spending time but it's the strategy and
insights to make what they like what
makes them tick and then providing that
whether through content form or event
for it's really one big game of reverse
engineering like this was something I've
wanted to do for years but until I felt
like everybody the bar majority people
would leave here ry+ on their investment
like the thought of like building up
everything I've built up we're like
YouTube brothers don't do it and then
leave and then say scary B's a farce I
spent 12,000 bucks and it didn't get me
anything that's just stupid business for
me I needed to get to a place where I
thought this was so overwhelming ROI
positive you know and that's how I think
about everything literally everything
sneakers wine vaynermedia until you're
you know until you get to a place and so
that's just what I want you to kind of
do it's like what does what and I can
have all my friends come in be the top
water guy and I
right but as I get more awareness in the
first-responder group I would love to
have a show of the fire fire comes to
the car wreck the ER nurse is the first
person in the hospital having like a
little drama with people throughout the
community that I don't know if you want
to go you listen you were just a
creative guy I can already sense that so
you just may want to do that
I actually think it's a little less ER
and law-and-order I think you make it a
little bit more so I'm a big fan and I'm
sure you guys have heard this about like
hosting the party I think one of the
things you can do is just create a
podcast network so like I think you
should go find two charismatic nurses
and start a Houston nursing show you're
the executive producer they're the
talent and that becomes a little viral
hit in that community you see where I'm
going I'll give you a real left-field
one if you want to be super creative
you could also this is crazy but I would
love for you to do this I think this is
super cool you could actually be the
livestreamer of the cops and
firefighters
safe ball League what if you acted like
ESPN had six people with live-streaming
and actually aired the softball league
games it's yeah I mean if you're lucky
enough and you live one of those towns
where the cops do play against the
firefighters like or you could literally
create the Thanksgiving game cops versus
firefighters get a field get a high
school to support it film it and air it
live on Facebook and own the you know
the first responders Cup you could
probably get a sponsor to come over and
subsidize all your [ __ ] feet you
could literally throw the [ __ ]
Thanksgiving game every [ __ ] Friday
each like you see where I'm going I
think it's a lot easier to throw I I
think the best thing you can throw is a
literal podcast it's the most likely
thing you can pull off is a podcast
network the next more likely thing you
can pull off is actually airing the
softball games or the football games
the last thing you're probably likely to
pull off is creating er in uh producing
a show that's hard as [ __ ] scripted
that's it Bret that's the French that's
the that's different that's different
that's different that's different but
less reoccurring than the things and be
one-off once your interview Karen
whereas whereas if you're doing a show
for four nurses in Houston and just a
culture of that and it's a call-in you
see where I'm going you want to create
things that are like scalable Wine
Library TV was amazing I tasted wine
which meant I could live for hundred
lifetimes and never get to every wine
right askgaryvee think about the shows
I've made the wine Wine Library TV
scalable in perpetuity I can't taste
every wine in my life
not in a hundred life's a scary be
unlimited questions from the audience
forever daily vlog I actually live just
filming there was there was never I
never had to create see where I'm going
see got it that's what you're looking
for
[Music]
[Music]
then I put open up top Instagram
hope but everybody Simon good afternoon
I'm about to go on a board call in 8
minutes so I don't have a whole lot of
time maybe five or six what's the next
Illuminati meaning people really believe
it out Illuminati [ __ ] oh yeah do you
believe in it tell the truth don't
[ __ ] don't go based on the way I set
up Jason speak your truth you know I
won't judge yes you do I think so I
don't know I'm kidding I'm kidding a
group alike just like dr. [ __ ] evil
sin I don't think there's like one dude
like behind the show of course there's
no one dude by the show this is not a
[ __ ] joke this is really me asking
for the first time I actually have no
idea what people think they look is the
Illuminati this theory that like
powerful people have a secret Club yeah
jay-z yeah I get it
right yeah but this is like that's much
more of a diamond than [ __ ] like like
but that's the punchline right got it I
mean there's definitely people that get
together and jam yeah but you believe in
Illuminati
you do you do you do yeah we've seen so
many YouTube videos like I'll finally
describe oh you want it to be real to be
in it I feel like I'm in the Illuminati
a club of one I think the coolest Club
I'm in is my [ __ ] head with myself
that's the [ __ ] Illuminati for me
that's the Illuminati I wish everybody
had being your own [ __ ] head with
yourself
that's [ __ ] Illuminati you want to
really [ __ ] [ __ ] like other high
net-worth individuals that are powerful
or famous or cool or good-looking but
that sounds like club of insecurities
and needing to [ __ ] fit into
something elitist the real Illuminati's
in your own [ __ ] the Dome Club of one
membership of
[Music]
walk with me presenters Thank You gang
thank you thanks for your help thank you
I'll see you guys later or back to the
office but it's good right that concept
is good yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now
thank you for being here I'm really
excited about tonight
you know Vayner has been a very organic
organization over the last decade and so
as we continue kind of into our next
phase we haven't done a whole lot of
events like this and so I'm just very
grateful for the pet team what we call
our HR team here and I just want to
thank all of you for putting this
together I was really excited about it
I also I also haven't been in the
kitchen for about a year and a half so
it's good to see that still here good
call Jason biggest mistake that people
make when they think about accolades is
the same reason that they dwell on the
booing you know it's funny that we're
talking about athletes you know over the
last decade I've built a lot of
friendships in that world and then over
the last half decade a lot of the world
has become this right and a lot of
people come to me because I grew up in
that world and people get down on like
somebody leaving a comment that's
negative and I'm like bro you plan
home-court give up an 11 Oh run and
everybody who's supposed to be your
homeys are booing you and you don't let
that face you cuz you're in that zone as
a human you need to be in that zone when
people say you're the greatest you need
to think you're crap when people say
you're crap you need to think you're the
greatest
and then that contradiction and pulling
from opposite directions when the flows
go in one way that's how you get your
actual balance that's how you get your
two fingers in your ears
you don't hear [ __ ] can I curse on this
thing good
you don't hear [ __ ] you don't hear if
they say you're gonna be the MVP in the
league your rookie year and you don't
hear if that you're the biggest bust of
all time the second you can get there
get into that place it's over and so
don't get too high or no supply your
clippings a lot of these kids have
serious heat some of these kids have the
most heat we've seen in a generation and
you know balancing that is imperative so
for me you know what I see in other A's
when I'm going through a little bit of
my little world is
just don't hear it one way or the other
[Music]